[Music]
good afternoon everyone
welcome to today's session on
subscriptions on Google Play I want to
give a special shout out to all the
people around the world watching us
right now on the livestream yeah whoo
my name is Larry yang I'm a product
manager on the Google Play billing
platform today I'm joined by my fellow
product manager Angela and our business
development lead Nico okay hi everyone
all right let's kick things off with a
quick show of hands who here is already
running a subscriptions business on
Google Play wow that's like half over
half the room that's awesome
all right who here is looking to get
started on running a subscriptions
business on Play all right that's like
about a third of the room that's awesome
well have good news for all of you today
we're going to run through a whole bunch
of features and capabilities that you
can use right now to start a
subscriptions business whether you're
already exist I already have an existing
business and you're looking to optimize
or grow or if you're just looking to get
something started but Before we jump in
let's take a quick look at why we're
even all here talking about
subscriptions subscriptions is one of
the fastest growing businesses on mobile
today and it's no surprise users have
been telling us that they love
subscriptions they love the value that
subscriptions provide and they love the
access to continuous fresh content that
they get via a subscription service and
users have demonstrated this love by
making subscriptions a part of their
daily lives in fact 62% of paid Android
subscribers use their subscription app
at least once every single day and
because users love subscriptions
developers love them too let's watch a
short video highlighting some of the
great success that you developers have
had on subscriptions on Google Play
[Music]
all right that's pretty cool huh so this
is a real testament to all the great
work that you developers have done on
subscriptions on Google Play but
together we can do so much more so today
we're gonna share three things with you
first we'll recap some of the features
we've rolled out recently and share some
of the successes that developers have
seen with those recent features next
we're going to announce a dozen new
features that you can put to work right
away to help grow your business and
finally we'll give a sneak peek at some
of the ideas that we have around the
corner but more importantly tell you how
what you can do today to be ready for
when those features are available so
Nico why don't you come on up and get us
started tell us about what some of the
successes developers are having today
thanks Larry the past twelve months have
been truly exciting for subscriptions on
Google Play we as a team have worked
hard to address the biggest challenging
biggest challenges you are facing as
developers for example minimizing churn
so quickly want to run through three
features we have seen successful
developers use to do just that
number one is real-time developer
notifications Reaper real-time developer
notifications give you immediate
notifications
when the subscriber state changes for
example a subscriber renews or cancels
essentially it changes the way you
operate your subscription business on
Google Play especially in regards to
minimizing subscriber churn
let me quote two of our top developers
on this feature brain training app
elevate says real-time developer
notifications have helped them identify
the exact moments a user cancels so they
can remind them of the benefits of a
subscription and it ties them to Reese
obscure a music streaming on our army
loves real-time developer notifications
because it lets them predict subscriber
churn real time and quickly target
canceling users with wind back offers
the bottom line is for developers
serious about retention real time
developer notifications have become a
must
secondly we invested quite a bit in
helping you combat involuntary churn
because it's just so painful you spend
all this time building a great product
or service then you convince users to
become subscribers to your product just
so they may turn because for example
there forgot to update their form of
payments that's what we have seen such
great success with grace period which
allows you to reap which allows us to
retry to charge subscribers whose
payment has failed for the final period
of time an account hold which lets you
put subscribers in a suspended States
until they update the four month payment
at the form of payment as you can see
here in the example provided by our
partner music Matt musiXmatch that's
notifying the user about the payment
that has failed lastly we've heard
really great feedback on the Play
console subscription reports we launched
at i/o last year on this stage actually
over there and how provides many ways to
analyze your business and find
optimization potential
developers ever have made it the primary
destination for business intelligence
for anybody working on subscriptions in
their company so to quickly summarize
our most successful developers show us
how these features help and build great
subscription services today so we
recommend all of you to check them out
if you're not already many ways okay
enough of features you already know I
want to welcome Angela to tell you all
about the new things we're announcing
thanks Nico we've talked about how much
users love subscriptions we strongly
believe that by building a great user
experience we're also building a high
quality subscriber base but we know that
the user experience is not always
perfect so just taking a quick quick
quick straw poll out there how many of
you have hesitated to sign up for a
subscription service because you thought
it would be too annoying to cancel or it
was just going to be a hassle to
remember I know I have and I see a bunch
of you guys have as well and this is
what we found that our user research
users told us that while they can derive
a lot of value out of their
subscriptions once they've signed up
they also feel like they'll be trapped
in the subscription without the ability
to cancel and since the majority of our
users also have multiple subscriptions
to manage they're worried that they'll
lose track of how much they're spending
these fears create a barrier for users
signing up for your subscription apps
and we want to address that fear and so
we're really too excited to announce
that we're launching a new subscription
center this is a one-stop shop for users
to manage their subscriptions in Google
Play we've done a complete UX overhaul
of our old subscriptions page to make it
easier for users to get more information
about their subscription easily fix
their payment issues and do other
actions such as restore their
subscription
but rather than talk about it let me
just show you how it works NECO has
graciously volunteered to be my demo
person yes could I get two forward on
the slides please
okay we're just gonna do this yeah so so
let's go to demo a yeah okay so Nico
could you open the Play Store and open
the hamburger menu okay so we're looking
at Vincent barrel ease account and we
can see that subscriptions is now in a
very prominent position on the hamburger
menu this is something new that has
already been launched so let's see what
happens when you go into subscriptions
so Vincent doesn't actually have any
subscriptions but there's a new empty
state with it get started link so let's
see what happens when you type gets
started when we tap get started we see
that there's a whole new selection of
different subscription apps that the
users can explore and keep in mind that
this is not the final version this is
something that our amazing merchandising
team is working on making a better
experience day after day so let's
actually see what the subscription
Center looks when the user has some
subscriptions can you switch to Wendy's
account please
okay so we can see that Wendi actually
has three subscriptions in her account
one of them has a payment decline which
needs to be addressed but in general we
can see that she has all this
information about her subscription
including the SKU name which is
something that we didn't have before and
in order to go in and manage a specific
subscription you just have to tap
somewhere so Nico let's tap on Pearl and
straw to manage that subscription so
let's say that Wendy just got a new
credit card and she wants to use that
for her subscription and she wants to
update that payment method so Nico lets
tap update under primary payment method
so now we can see all the payment
methods that Wendy has in her account so
let's go ahead and switch that to the
new to the new credit card so we're done
now right well we've actually launched a
cool new feature so you could either tap
got it and you know Wendy can go back to
enjoying her bubble tea subscription or
we can tap add back up to add a back up
payment method which is a payment method
that will charge in case the primary
fails and this is also a new feature
that we're that we have already launched
and is available today so let's go ahead
and use that old credit card as the
backup awesome and so now we're all set
so let's switch back to the slides
please sorry
okay with the launch assist the
subscription Center we're also launching
new deep links specifically designed for
developers you can direct your users to
manage or fix their subscriptions from
your app over email over web really over
any platform and it's super easy to
implement all you really need is the
pack name and the SKU name to construct
the deep link and then you can put that
deep link in a button or a link from any
of your properties so let's cut back the
donut up to the demo to see how this
works so Nico I need my yak fix can you
open the fabulous yeah cap sure oh man I
wanted to access that premium article
about yaks but all I see is a dead yak
so I guess let's manage payment methods
and see what happens okay so I just
followed the deep link and now I'm in
the manage subscription page for the
fabulous yak out and I can see that
there's an action required so there's a
problem with my account and that the
awesome thing is that there's Alice's
CTA for me to fix this problem so let's
go ahead and fix that problem so it
looks like the old credit card which is
actually the credit card which we wanted
to update earlier has been declined
so let's go ahead and update that to the
new one
awesome so now it looks like the
subscription that's been updated why
don't we check whether we can access the
Yaak premium subscription again nice the
payments been fixed and we're back to
the premium experience and that yak is
so happy she's just over the moon with
joy let's cut back to the slides please
finally and very very excited to
announce that we'll be launching a
survey to users for when they cancel the
subscription this is a feature that many
many of you have asked for and you can
access the survey answers through our
server-side API today and eventually
you'll be also be able to see the
answers in console reporting so we're
still rolling out the user facing
changes but because we've already
launched the API if you query it today
you'll see a small percentage of the
antlers that users have already input so
let's get back to the demo to see how
this works so Nico let's go to the Play
Store and to Wendy's account again
so Wendy is not only a big fan of yaks
she also loves narwhals but she's gotten
kind of tired of the narwhal monthly
newsletter so let's just cancel that
subscription for her so let's go into
Narwhal and then it's really easy we
just tap cancel subscription now what we
see is a quick user for the use as those
quick survey for the user to give the
developers some feedback as to why
they're cancelling and there are already
a few pre-written answers but wendy has
a pretty specific reason and can select
other to type in that reason so Nico she
told you what that reason was right she
did indeed she said they're not enough I
mean I guess they are an endangered
species so that makes sense alright
let's finish canceling that subscription
cool and the nice thing is even if
tomorrow Wendy wakes up and she's
realized she's made a huge mistake she
can actually go back and restore her
subscription in the subscription center
so let's go ahead and restore that
subscription
awesome so now Wendy can continue to
enjoy her non-real subscription even
next month and that's it for the demo so
let's go back to the presentation at
Google we've always believed that if you
focus on the user all else will follow
because of this new user first
experience to easily manage
subscriptions users will trust our store
and engage more with your apps with the
subscription Center we'll also be able
to deliver more capabilities to you the
developer the deep linking canceled
survey are just two examples of these
new abilities so let's go back to Larry
anik who will tell you about the other
new developer features that we're coming
out with thanks Angela Thank You Angela
can we get a round of applause for a
flawless demo execution so when I'm not
busy demoing things that I also to say
in real life I'm part of the Google Play
business development team the Google
Play business development team works
with on a daily basis works directly
with subscription developers of all
kinds of backgrounds around the world
naturally we hear a lot of feedback and
ideas for features which we then take to
our p.m. teams such as Larry or Angela
and to see how how we can solve these
things we hear about so one of the
request is that you developers told us
you want more flexibility in issuing
refunds to your users current currently
on the server-side API you can only
refund the latest subscription order
using the purchase token you cannot
issue a refund using the order ID it
should refund for previous subscription
orders or do partial refunds and that's
really not ideal when dealing with
subscribers well I have great news for
you Nico and for everyone here
we've now closed these gaps we're
extending the server-side API now to
support refunds using order IDs that
means now you can
refund a specific subscription renewal
not just the latest one and starting
today you can also issue partial refunds
you can do that on the play console you
can actually go over to our sandbox
afterwards and see a demo of that in
action and this feature will also be
available on our server-side API next
week
cool I'm sure that will make a lot of
developers really happy another request
we've heard a lot it's maybe the longest
longest standing feature request that I
personally know of is price changes at
the moment you cannot change the price
of an SKU once it's been created
obviously that is very limiting for
businesses especially for businesses
whose costs have gone up so currently
the only way to do this is to create a
new SKU and get users to upgrade that
also means that you the developers have
to do all the heavy lifting like
messaging users or canceling users who
don't operate so we've heard so much
about this feature from Niko and other
business of element partners that we
figured the easiest way to make them
happy was to just build the feature so
I'm pleased to announce we now support
mandatory price changes on existing SKUs
alright so let's say you need to roll
out a price change to all your users
maybe your cost of content has gone up
or the tax structure has changed in one
of the countries you do business in so
now all you need to do is you go to the
Play console choose the country or
countries where you need to change the
price enter the new price and click Save
and you're done 30 days before the users
renewal date we start sending we play
start sending emails and push
notifications asking the user to agree
to that price change we also give you
the developer a seven-day head start so
you can also message the user in app
if that renewal date comes and the user
has not agreed to the price change we
will take care of canceling that user
this feature is currently in early
access if you're interested in trying it
out and joining our Early Access program
please visit the link that you see on
the screen here I think it's so awesome
that we finally let developers do that
give you that flexibility to actually
build your business
I'm sure developers will love this
additional flexibility and building
their subscription business on play
which actually brings me to another ask
I mentioned earlier how much developers
love the subscription reports and that
retention is the key topic so what we've
heard quite a bit is that you developers
ask for reports that provide even more
details especially on the topics on
retention and cancellations so Larry I
know we have a lot to share here you
want to jump right in yep so we have a
lot of great news in this area as well
so at i/o last year we announced a brand
new subscriptions dashboard a lot of
developers have told us that they love
their reports and many of our top
developers use those reports every day
to gain insights onto their business but
you have all asked for more capabilities
which is why we've extended to new
capabilities in our subscription reports
let's take a quick look at what those
are
first we're creating a new retention
report now it's super easy to go in and
look at specific cohorts say by SKU or
dates or by country now you can also
drill into your free trial conversion
and others interesting metrics in this
report and you can also look
specifically at how many renewal periods
various users in the cohorts have
advanced through after all that's the
name of the game when you're running a
subscriptions business so the second
change we're making is we're making
improvements to the cancellation report
here's where you will see
the data from the cancellation survey
that Angela Nikko showed you earlier and
will also give you details on how your
wind back and your retention features
are performing such as a count hold and
grace period all in all this feature
will be rolling out over the next few
weeks and it's going to help
subscription developers like you
understand and optimize your entire user
lifecycle you can get more details on
our new reporting capabilities in
tomorrow's session on analyzing and
benchmarking over on stage 3 at 9:30
tomorrow morning ok in already I said a
lot but are you done now I think we have
more oh wait no I got a few more things
like I just got a squeeze in we our
engineers have so much stuff just just
give me a few more seconds oh I said oh
in the meantime I wish we had more time
they told us they're gonna just cut us
off with at the end of this session so
just real quick here there's a couple of
other things with the world I want to
share with you all you all have asked
for the ability to do quicker renewals
on your test subscriptions so we've now
rolled that capability out for example a
monthly subscription a monthly test
subscription will now renew in just five
minutes you also wanted the ability to
create an intro price period that's
different from your regular recurrence
period
so we've now rolled out that capability
so you could say for example offer a
dollar for 90 days and then kick in to
$10 a month on your subscription and
finally we have the capability for you
to offer an upgrade but keep the users
renewal date and charge an incremental
prorated price this last feature is only
available with the play billing library
which you'll hear a little bit more
about later
alright thanks Larry I think my brain
hurts from trying to remember all those
new features he's just covered so let's
just recap we've launched 12 new
features in total both for users and for
developers on the user side we've
created a better user experience with
the new subscription center including
app discovery backup payment method new
deep linking and a cancel survey for the
developer we're going to view a ton more
flexibility including improved refunds
ability to change SKU prices
and advance supporting and more we've
bolded the features that are available
now so go check them out as soon as you
can all of these other features were
working out on rolling out in the next
couple of weeks so these are the
features that we've been working on this
past year but what are we going to do
next year and the year after that Larry
you want to tell them more yes so these
features we just shared are things you
can use right now to grow your business
but we're not done our engineers are
hard at work coming up with new features
that you that will help you acquire and
retain your subscribers so for example
imagine if your users could sign up
outside of your app say from the Play
Store or from anywhere else on the web
well what if your users could pay with
cash or what if we offered the option
for users to temporarily pause their
subscription instead of outright
canceling them or maybe we can help you
win back users by getting them to
reactivate a subscription well after the
subscription has expired okay but wait a
sec Larry it's exciting as that sounds
does it mean that every single time we
lounge one of these new features our
developers have to rewrite all of their
code you know I knew you're gonna ask
that so we've we've thought a lot about
this so our goal is to be able to build
all these features in such a way so that
you don't have to do you do as little
work as possible our goal is to get as
close as possible to zero integration
and we want that to happen on both the
client-side with your app as well as on
your server-side integration that sounds
great but how are you going to do that
alright just just relax I got this all
right I mean let me just give me a few
minutes I'll talk through how we're
gonna make this happen all right so
first let's talk about what you need to
do on your client-side so last fall at
playtime we announced version 1.0 of the
play billing library the play building
library is an abstraction layer on top
of your Adel file API updates are picked
up automatically when you update your
build dependency file and the next time
compiled your app so now there's no more
searching reference code sample code and
copying it and hoping you got the right
version and all that it's all taken care
of I'm at eclis today we're announcing
version 1.1 of the play building library
this version includes the feature I
mentioned earlier where you can upgrade
and keep the expiration date and we when
we roll out price changes that feature
will also only be available via the Play
billing library using the Play billing
library is very very simple there's just
three easy steps now since no i/o
presentation is complete without showing
some code I'm gonna go and show a few of
the code examples for this now you're
probably thinking oh no we're near the
end of the session now you're gonna show
me a bunch of code don't worry the whole
point of showing you this code is to
show you just really how little code it
takes to use the billing library so
first all you need to do is add this one
line to your build that Gradle
dependency file second you need to of
course create the billing client
instance and to do that create set up
the listener and connect to Google Play
of course don't forget to build your own
retry retry policy in case your client
loses a connection and the third and
final step is of course to call the
proper method as you go through your
purchase lifecycle just like you do
today that's it okay I'm convinced it's
so straightforward that even I get it
and it's actually very close to zero
integration but you know still it's late
afternoon and I think we've had enough
slides with code so and then at the end
of the day what really matters is how
developers actually like it and my
favorite quote here comes from Joe Burge
he's an Android
Angele that buffer and he's also a
Google developer expert who called in
Google Play Building library a dream
come true and we're making this dream
come true for thousands of developers
today already so if you like me did not
memorize the code on those slides note
on this link here
on the slide to learn more so remember
with the play billing library one your
integration is much much simpler just a
lot less code to manage new features
will be well rolling out in the future
will only be available using the play
billing library currently it's only
available for Java and Kotlin developers
but a C++ version is coming soon okay so
that's what you need to do on your
client side now what here's what you
need to do on your server side earlier
we talked about real time developer
notifications let me go through a little
bit of detail what it is and how you can
use it today and then how it'll prepare
you for the future so with real time
developer notifications you set up a
Google cloud pub/sub integration and we
send you real-time messages whenever
important events happen with your users
subscription the for example when you
have a new user that signs up or an
existing user that renews will send you
a message and you now know you need to
continue or you need to grant a new
entitlement or continue to grant
entitlement to that user if today you've
integrated and implemented account hold
and by the way in case you weren't
looking in that video you really really
should integrate with account hold we
now send you a real-time developer
notification when the user has a payment
issue and goes on hold or when the user
recovers from their payment issue and
they come off hold so now immediately
you will know when to withhold
entitlement or to grant back entitlement
to that user this is super important if
you have a service that operates
cross-platform
say you have users who sign up on
Android but might consume on web or
other mobile platforms real time
developer notifications also tell you
about voluntary cancellation where the
user chooses to cancel in this situation
when you get that message right away you
should start trying to win back that
user maybe remind the user about some
new content that's coming up or tell
them about some features that you notice
that they haven't used in your app and
using the deep link that Angela toe
about earlier you then drive the user
back to the subscription Center where
they click on the restore button and
with one tap there they become an active
subscriber again so these are some of
the things you can do today
right now with real-time developer
notifications but in the future if you
integrate now you'll be ready for some
of the new things that will be rolling
out like say you user temporarily pause
with their subscription we'll send you a
developer notification so you'll know
that's happened or if we got a user to
reactivate their subscription after it's
expired you'll get a real-time developer
notification and you now know to grant
entitlement back but remember with
real-time developer notifications the
notification is only telling you that a
subscription state has changed
you still need to call or server-side
API and query the full state of the
subscription and know exactly what you
need to do exactly what action you need
to take with that subscriber so as I
mentioned earlier we attempt developer
notification has become an essential
part of our top developed top developer
subscription set up check out the
details on how to set up real-time
developer notifications under this link
which takes you to the developer pages
and has all the details so remember if
you want a future proof for your
integration be sure to use both the Play
billing library on your client-side and
integrate with real-time developer
notifications on the server side alright
whew that was a lot of stuff so give us
a couple minutes here we're just gonna
real quick recap all the stuff that
you'll be introduced and told you about
so we started off with talking about how
much you just love subscriptions thanks
to the great work you have done thanks
to the great products and subscription
services you've launched and your
operating we've shared with you 12 new
features including many features built
around the new subscription center and
finally we talked about how you can use
the Play billing library and integrate
with real time developer notifications
so that you're ready as we were all out
new features yeah because obviously this
is only day 1 of i/o so there is
there are more great sessions that you
should definitely check out so we want
to recommend you is the 6:00 p.m.
session on games today which will also
talk about subscriptions and games and
then tomorrow at 9:30 you can learn much
more about all the great reports we only
touched on today you can also check out
demos of a lot of the features we've
announced in the sandbox which is over
there and we also have an office hours
specifically for Google Play
subscriptions tomorrow at 2:30 p.m. if
you have more questions join us over at
the Android and play conversations area
right after this session I think it's
just on the other side of the wooden
deck to your right as you walk out and
lastly we would love to get your
feedback after all how is Nico gonna get
better at his jokes if we don't give
them feedback okay that's it everyone
thank you very much and enjoy the rest
of your IO
[Applause]
[Music]